hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the aim chess rapid knockout we
are in the finals um uh still and it is
Young shisht of Duda versus
the first day of their match he won two
games two games were drawn and Nama
midarov needs to strike back in order to
force tie breaks and this game is
absolutely unbelievable as usual when
mamidarov is involved usually you have
some 20 moves of known Theory and then
something just happens something
explodes uh and then we all enjoy that
so let's see what happened here Duda has
the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 direty is on the board we
have Pawn to D5 D4 uh Knight to F6 and
now Pawn to C4 going for the uh well or
offering the gambited pawn and now the
captures on C4 Mama Yara accepts the
queen Gambit we have Pawn to E3 going
after the the C4 pawn and now Pawn to E6
with Bishop captures and C4 and fantasy
five so the classical fence nothing new
being played here we have castle spawn
to A6 preparing B5 Pawn to B3 and pawn
to B5 busher back to E2 Bishop to B7 and
now Bishop to B2 again all been played
before Knight B to D7 Pawn to a for
challenging the structure on the queen
Side Pawn to B4 and now Knight B to D2
with Bishop to E7 and Rook the C1 we
have rooked the C8 and now Knight the C4
by dude a beautiful Square for this
Knight we have castles and now Knight F
to E5
uh seat counters on D4 Knight captures
on D7 Knight captures and D7 and Bishop
captures on D4 now with Bishop to D5 uh
and now uh there is a game where Queen
to D2 was played also Pawn to A5 is a
known move but here we have Queen to D3
and it is now as of move 17 that we have
a completely new game so what's the idea
behind Queen to D3 and why is
um a young sist of inviting Knight to C5
to go after the queen well he wants to
re-maneuver the queen to B1 so he can
shift this Rook to D1 and align it with
the black queen on d8 so let's see what
happens here Knights the C5 by shark
they are queen back to B1 also you have
to defend your B3 pawn and now Knight
the E4 social
immensely improves the position of his
Knight but now Rook F to D1 and this
already looks uh very unpleasant for
black so you have to be very careful
about what you do here and here uh
Bishop to F6 by mamadarov and this is
not the most precise way to deal with
this position or you know maybe it is if
you're a human if you're an engine then
you know probably not but feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
uh the well the the tiniest way to take
advantage of the position while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well positional uh brilliancy and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Bishop to F3 and now black
has all sorts of problems because now
the Knight on e4 is hanging so what can
you do here let's explore just some of
the options let's say we play Bishop
captures on D4 first you want to take
some pressure off the board then Bishop
captures an E4 and now your Bishop is
hanging and also the H7 Pony singing so
if you capture an E4 they're just Queen
captures and E4 and next You're Gonna
Lose the bishop end of the game so yeah
obviously that's not gonna work uh
probably best for black is the plain
Knight the G5 which just gives white a
long-term positional advantage through a
force line of Bishop captures on D5 e
captures on D5 and now a nice Bishop
captures on F6 where if you capture with
the queen you just give up the D5 Pawn
for nothing so you're gonna have to mess
up your Pawn structure and now okay
white just goes back Knight to D2 and
now black skin inside is ruined and the
white will play against this position
what happened in the game is that
mamajara played Knight the C3 he
attacked the queen and the Rook but this
is now winning for Duda and it's not um
hard to see why or it's not easy to find
why it's winning because obviously we're
not going to give up any material Bishop
captures on C3 B captures on C3 and now
Pawn to E4 and The Duda has just won a
bishop or so you would think uh because
mamidarov did plan on this and he plays
Bishop captures on C4 so Duda does not
get the bishop he gets the queen but
mamidara will get a bishop and a rook in
return so Rook capture 78 Rook F capture
78 and now B captures and C4 so grabbing
the bishop as well and now the situation
is Queen rook and Bishop versus uh Rook
rook and Bishop so now Amir only has a
rook for a queen but what uh another
thing he does have is a protected pass
born on C3 so can he actually do
something with this position uh you know
everything you know about Chess should
tell you that no a queen is just too
powerful of a piece but okay Rook the B8
attacks the White Queen we have Queen to
A1 and this is by far the best uh Square
for the queen if you go somewhere like
Queen tatoo then you allow Rook to D2 to
come with Tempo so Queen to A1 and now
comes Rook the B2 of course uh if uh if
you allow uh Rook captures on C3 might
even be an option in some lines because
you would gladly give up The Rook for
pawn and Bishop just uh you know uh take
care of any and all counter play Black
might have so Rook the B2 of course
mommy Dr will not allow this and now the
position is incredibly intense and what
Duda should do is just start pushing his
pass Pawn as one usually should but he
played E5 and everyone was confused uh
when Duda played this okay you you free
up your your Bishop's diagonal but do
you even need that okay at some point
you will need it to cover the C6 Square
maybe but it just allows my media of a a
whole lot more than he had so Bishop
captures an E5 now it's very hard to
take care of the back rank issues
something like h3h4 is no longer as
great as the bishop will Now cover the
H3 H2 square and G3 then the Rooks come
to the second rank will also be an issue
it's okay Queen to A3 by Duda and now we
have Pawn to G6 by mamidarov he also has
to take care of some background issues
you could also play something like C2
and it's it's in fact a great move but
uh yeah my major feels that he can do
even better if C2 then G3 and if Rook to
B1 then what you play King G2 and now
after Bishop to B2 going after the queen
and the Rook Queen to B3 or A2 doesn't
really matter you're gonna capture the
C2 Pawn you give up The Rook Queen
captures on C2 and now okay you have to
defend your Rook so you're either gonna
move it or replace them like Rook D to
B8 but now white starts pushing and yes
you want material but this Pawn is now
looking
um uh very strong so instead my Madera
plays G6 he gives Duda uh the uh
opportunity if you will to make a
mistake and The Duda plays G3 uh here uh
the the position is still very very good
for do that he he needs to find King to
F1 and it looks like such a weird move
why would you go closer to Black's
pieces he has a rook Bishop the other
rook and a pass Pawn here point is that
after C2 there's King E2 and now you
don't have to worry about the Rook on
the second rank you don't have to worry
about Rook to D2 you're on a light
Square you don't have to worry about the
bishop and especially you don't have to
worry about Rook to B1 because the Rook
is no longer pinned by the King on the
first rank so you can just play Rook
captures and C2 so King E2 solves all of
your problems none of none of black
species can touch you so incredible but
who would who would see this so instead
after G6 dude I played Pawn to G3 he did
create a square for his King but now
mamidaro just drops the the other Rook
to the second rank Rook D to D2 going
after the F2 Pawn Rook captures on C3
now happily grabbing that pass Pawn but
now Rook to A2 attacks the queen and now
Queen to C1 is the final attempt at
saving the game after Queen to B4 it's
just a very very hard to play this if
not impossible Bishop to D4 now going
after the F2 pawn and now again it's uh
maybe you can save this but through a
you know a very long struggle you would
have to go into some terrible terrible
end game some like King to F1 has to be
played and will captures an F2 check
King E1 and now let's say Rook if the B2
threatening Rook the A1 check so you
have to play Rook to B3 in order just to
stay alive Rook the A1 check Bishop to
D1 now look at this bishop to F2 check
King F1 Rook captures on D1 grabbing the
bishop King G2 and now Bishop to C5 with
check grabbing the queen so Rook
captures on B2 Bishop captures real
captures and you would get this position
where mamidar would be up a pawn uh do
the would have a past C Pawn but you
still have to put a rook behind it and
it's just it's not going to be like Rook
D2 Rook to C2 and already mamidar has a
rule behind that pawn so it's either
winning or maybe Duda can save it with
some perfect play but that's only if he
finds King to F1 and he missed it once
already he misses it for the second time
he plays Pawn to C5 but now it's just
the game over Bishop captures on F2 with
check
King to F1 and now a nice Rook the A1
with check now if you go to G2 you go
under the mask of The Rook so Bishop
captures on C5 with check just picks up
the queen for nothing so after Rook day
one check Rook the C1 was played at
least you will force force the other
Rook to move now Rook captures on C1
with check King to G2 and now just a
nice Bishop to E1 uh with check now you
don't have Bishop captures on C5 because
of Queen character Sunday too but now
Bishop to E1 opens up a discovery and he
was in this position on move 34 that
Yanks used of Duda resigned to the game
and what a brilliant brilliant victory
for mamidyar of giving up a queen for
just a rook in the in the past Pawn but
you've seen the potential of the
position you've seen uh what what a
great uh player like mamidarov can do
and uh against another spectacular a
spectacular player like Duda in The
Knockouts of the anxious rapid Duda
faced with it he faced Agnes Carlson and
he already played one full day of four
games against mamidarov and he did not
lose a single game so that's how strong
Duda is and now my major takes him down
like this with the black pieces
well I mean my my day is going uh very
well I hope you guys enjoyed this game
and yeah yeah here we resign because
after King th3 the very simple moving
The Rook away with temple Rook captures
an H2 check will pick up White's Queen
and that's it Rook captures on H2 Bishop
captures on B4 and now you are up a full
Rook uh which is kind of funny because
mamidarov gave up a queen for a rook and
now he's up that full Rook so that could
be that Rook I mean very nice so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh brilliant stuff by by do the out
preparing mama drama like that with a
bishop to the F3 line but what mamidarov
did that I mean I I have no words
uh so I really hope you guys enjoyed
that I would like to thank ravishing
reptiles YouTube Trevor Terrace
luxeminarian at chakrapani Allen psycho
and listerpan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day